okay let's talk about the third sexting
scandal involving former New York
Congressman Anthony Weiner yet again
caught sexting women we Weiner gate 2011
is it is uh come to be known led to
anthony Weiner's resignation as a
congressman then in 2013 he was running
for mayor of New York City
three women expose that he had been
sexting with them that ended his mayoral
run and now this taking place in 2015
but being revealed over the last 24 to
48 hours yet again a report that Anthony
Weiner was sexting with another woman
this time ending his marriage to Hillary
Clinton confidant Huma Abedin who has
said she is leaving Anthony Weiner the
concern now is their son speaking of
their son if you're looking at this
picture that we are displaying and the
new Weiner sexting a picture uh
apparently a picture in which he was
very very excited to say the least and
his son a baby at the time is in the
picture that he sexted to this woman
that he was in touch with and indeed the
New York Times now reporting that a
weiner and Abedin have separated now I
don't care that much about Anthony
Weiner and his sexting the guy clearly
is having a major major problem this is
completely humiliating to his wife
Hillary Clinton's advisor Huma Abedin
this is not good for their son this is
clearly a guy with serious issues but
I'm more interested in how Donald Trump
all of a sudden is in the middle of this
disastrous scandal by trying to critique
Hillary Clinton as a result Donald Trump
actually saying there is blame here for
Hillary Clinton
this is from a Donald Trump statement on
Hillary Clinton's bad judgment Abedin
Trump said quote is making a very wise
decision I know Anthony Weiner well and
she will be far better off without him
adding I only worry for the country in
that Hillary Clinton was careless and
negligent in allowing Weiner to have
such close proximity to highly
classified information who knows what he
learned and who he told it's just
another example of Hillary Clinton's bad
judgment it is possible that our country
and its security have been greatly
compromised by this let me remind you
that Donald Trump is on his third wife
has a reputation for being a womanizer
has any number of problems I would have
stayed out of it if I were Donald Trump
but apparently Donald Trump couldn't so
then let's analyze what he's saying
Trump is saying that individuals two
layers of separation removed from the
candidate those associations are
problematic I hate to break it to Trump
but if you were to look at everybody
who's two layers away from Donald Trump
there would be some disturbing people in
there and I don't think that this is a
door Donald Trump wants to open he's not
afraid of any door at this point
anything is just good press to him he's
gonna talk about everyone he's gonna say
weird things about Dwyane Wade's cousin
being murdered yes
anything's open for this classless
monster Trump's critique is just so
flaccid uh for lack of a better term
because if he really had a problem with
Anthony Weiner's behavior he wouldn't be
associated with the people he's
associated with like Roger Ailes who has
now been accused of sexual harassment by
20 women just for fun here's a reminder
from a press conference after one of
Anthony Weiner's previous sexting
scandals this is when the Howard Stern
shows Benjy Bronk showed up and asked
what I admit were some really funny
questions of Anthony Weiner take a look
at this message but I certainly wouldn't
obviously do the things that I have done
that that led me that that led me that
led me to this place
of course of course I would no I did not
I did not
yes
they were inappropriate they were part
of a consensual
you know exchanges of emails and I don't
want to violate the privacy of the women
who were involved but it was clearly
mistaken one that I deeply thank you
Anthony Weiner taking any and all
questions taking me I I don't like to
make light of what is a horrible family
situation for Huma Abedin but showing up
and asking Anthony Weiner number one
whether he was shocked that Arnold
Schwarzenegger had sex with quote such
an ugly woman number two whether he
would help the support Arnold
Schwarzenegger his love child
and number three whether in the gray
panties he was fully aroused or capable
of more that is a level of parody that I
find absolutely hilarious to actually
hear him say yes to the love child or
even answering a different question we
can tell the thing it looked like he was
saying yes he would help to support our
Arnold's love child
this may be the end now I'm more
comfortable saying this is the end of
Anthony Weiner's political career
Gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low use price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s the games
are shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s